how do you get the reality show you guys
are on e um well I think there's I mean
the dynamic of having 10 kids my mom and
Bruce between the two of them there's 10
of us
um we all were kind of hanging out and
La Hollywood you know being seen and you
know my mom met up with Ryan Seacrest
and they came up with this idea and
because Ryan Seacrest felt the family
was interesting yes sometimes it seems
on the show that Kim gets more attention
than let's say Chloe and Chloe you get
jealous so you get like hey we have a
family business Kim's making all the
decisions she's calling all the shots
who the [__] is she she's just one of
the sisters my favorite episode was when
they found out that you and your mom had
made the perfume the fragrance yeah talk
to me about that is Kim in a sense too
full of herself
it's not I don't get upset about Kim
um making decisions sometimes I feel
like Courtney and I and Kim we make all
these we work so hard but then Kim's the
one like that gets all the credit for it
we're always but Courtney and I Courtney
just doesn't speak up I I'm very vocal
what is the work in other words putting
out products going out to these clubs
and doing the television show right
that's the thing I do all the club
appearances by myself except for New
Year's the last do you guys put all the
same money in the same pot in other
words uh when it comes from our Dash
like we have we're designing for BB for
Five Seasons we have a virgin Saints and
Angel jury line coming out that we
designed for like all the stuff that we
do together that all goes in one point
yeah you have to split that with your
mom too no sure because she's our
management let me understand
show up at a club and you bring your
friends and 40 Grand later you're kind
of you know you're having a party you
can drink I don't drink alcohol I just
don't like it do with these clubs
she is boring at the clubs don't get me
you don't but I'm sure that type that
sits in the VIP Club and just doesn't
like ignores everyone I go out and I
like she doesn't I Don't Dance she
doesn't dance and what does she do she
said something no I talk to you
they make fun of you and all I do is
stand there and like show my ass and
I'll be like I like it
foreign